[Music]
as the Wailing becomes louder it's
Daybreak in Gaza where there's been
months of suffering and immense
destruction like every other morning the
bodies are then piled on
trucks these are victims of Israeli
bombing in Bal in central
Gaza another mother carries her child
One Last Kiss From the sister
one last chance to feel a departing
loved
one one after the other the dead are
gathered on the
ground God is sufficient for us says
this
grandmother an Israeli drone muffles the
morning of these mothers fathers
husbands brothers and sisters
allahar and the Drone is louder than the
funeral
prayer on day 122 there's no letup in
the bombardment of densely populated
Palestinian
areas as Israeli forces withdrew from
some parts this is what remains of much
of
Gaza more than 2third of the population
is displaced many of the 1.7 million
displaced people have been pushed out
multiple times as the places where they
took Refuge are also being attacked by
Israeli
forces another attack in another family
buried under their
home we managed to recover some dead
bodies from the rubble this Residential
Building had four floors a dozen
families were inside the Israeli planes
leveled It To The Ground more than 100
persons not one or two more than 100
mostly women and children were killed
this is a
crime more wounded are brought to the IL
equipped and short of supplies Alexa
Hospital doctors call it tragic since
many of the critically wounded die
because they cannot provide the required
care it's too dangerous to operate in
central Gaza because of Israeli forces
and
snipers as night falls more women and
children who make up 75% of the killed
and wounded call out in
pain no se fire no end to the Carnage
just the end of another brutal day in
Gaza B jaid
Al make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer